when it comes to revising, RE is very,
very similar to how I revise history,
but I didn't revise it as much as I did history.
so my exam board was at Excel A.
My first paper was Catholic Christianity,
second paper was Judaism,
and my 3rd paper was philosophy and ethics
for Catholic Christianity.
firstly, if you're doing the same exam board that I did
get, this book,
it is literally the condensed version
of the textbook that we use in school.
and again, a lot of the pages are either one page long
or like 2 or 3 pages long max,
and it's condensed.
and not only that,
but they have essay plans and practice questions.
so, for example,
you can find some of the essay plans
and the example essays that they write at the back.
and the notes they give you
are really easy to understand.
when it came to learning
so as which did
for sources of wisdom,
mother routine,
I use flashcards,
but I didn't use all of the quotes that I memorized
because I used essay plans,
and I would only use relevant quotes
or short quotes that I could just easily
write down and explain briefly.
are was very similar to history.
you want to use essay plans.
so literally, for re,
what I would do is
I would answer as many of the past
paper questions as I could,
and I would plan the.
the 12 markers.
I wouldn't actually write them.
like all of them.
but I would plan them
like history.
they like to recycle questions.
like, I'm not kidding,
one of the 12 markers was literally the reverse
of one of the questions in a past people question.
and one of the 5 markers was literally word for word
for the 2021 paper, I believe.
also, unlike English and history,
if you stick to a certain structure in RE,
you'll get the marks.
so when it comes to your structure and your answers,
it's very repetitive.
like, you don't need to sound like you're doing a lot.
you need to stick to saying your point,
your evident explanation,
and then you link it back to the question
and then you're done.
what I did in the paper was that
I would do the 12 markers first,
and then I would do the 5 marker,
then the full marker,
then the 3 marker,
because then it put my mind at ease
because I got out the bigger chunk of the paper first.
what I was told
and when I found out
is that you don't need to know the sources
word for word.
literally could be like in Marx gospel
and then explain the source.
if you don't know the source. however,
I would still recommend that you remember the sources
just in case
the examiner you get is quite picky.
in my school
we were also encouraged to make
tables to summarize information
and it just help little down
the pieces of evidence
that I could use
also. you wanna practice writing questions?
and something that really help me
was to teach people the content.
because then you're learning
and they're learning, too.